em eps have delivered a clear message to
member states seeking extra time to pay
additional contributions demanded last
month by the european union no to
deferring payment the demand followed
new calculations and left several EU
countries with big bills and others with
rebates any Peas insisted that EU
financial commitments must be respected
rouge oz oz eau de Sade are available
significative dominica toes atop a
disposable pub stabilizer DB instability
epoca de la moto def hakuna PA Hasan's
na atlanta ha ala father's attorney
let's not me after all during the last
Council summit UK Prime Minister David
Cameron made it clear that he would not
pay the extra two billion euros since
then however Britain's position has
softened there have been negotiations
which has spread the payment over a
period of time which will enable a
rebate on some of that payment and it
made it an infrared interest free for
over that period now the UK government
accepts it the EU Canada agreement on
the exchange of air passenger data is
still in the balance last June Canada
and the council gave their green light
but today MEP s decided to ask the
European Court of Justice to rule on the
legality of the dealer what we do is
that we we are we are really given the
folders here to the European Court of
Justice and we make them make sure that
what we politically intend to do is in
full compliance if it's not then we need
to to reopen the issue and and make it
right supporters of the deal say the
gathering and exchange of air passenger
data is crucial in the fight against
terrorism the figures alone are chilling
32 million women in Europe have fallen
victim to acts of physical or sexual
violence facing such statistics any PS
have urged the European permission to
draw up a new binding law to tackle the
issue arigato mr. Maku naveen our moon
is a socially dispo
Steve the huevos de puta que son defense
a video incred monteverdi Isola
legislation panel chief Osceola mo ha
fox a las calles FM some view limeros mo
in the same dispositive anka dress a fam
pasiphae's on certain news Mempa deposit
plant em eps have also called for the
establishment of a European Observatory
for violence against women and for a
year to be dedicated to the cause